moving sucks
you know
strangers handling your belongings the
movers always break something
[Music]
it's not gonna be first month or last my
friend one month security deposit i'll
get the paperwork started
i have finished the kitchen i finished
my bedroom i finished the office
and i'm just wrapping up the living room
okay so here i'll get pack-a-lacking i
love it i love it uh mind if i put on
some music i do not i do not i got this
new dubstep uh that's uh what is i don't
know what that is
oh dude you're gonna love it oh cool
cool man
[Music]
i like this
wait for the drop i'm sorry the drop
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
what is that
the music
i'm sorry is that music oh yeah dude
that's the dubstep man that's my jam
well it's it's a little uh loud and
disorienting and you know you're being a
little rough with my things ruffle dude
your stuff is fine
why am i sweating so much because you're
feeling it is that a good thing yes
come on man just give it another shot
okay
okay i will
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
dude you're totally jacking my flow up
dude your nose is bleeding and so is
mine
awesome um it doesn't really seem like
music to me
okay wow wally getting a little bit old
no all right do that come on no didn't
realize that okay um yeah what would you
rather listen to i can hook you up with
some hoodie on the blowfish if that's
your oh that's funny is that good color
me bad you know what go ahead i don't
care i see what you're doing go ahead
and play it i don't care because i'm not
that old i can get into it okay we just
let's just get this stuff packed play it
[Music]
trump
[Music]
[Applause]
oh thank you i wish i could just stay at
my old place but i can't afford the new
rent yeah moving sucks
you know strangers handling your
belongings the movers always break
something oh no i can't afford
professional movers i'm moving myself to
saturday
[Music]
going back and forth
back but do you think you can borrow
your roommate's band you can help me
with some of the big stuff
um
yeah
you know what
i've been thinking a lot lately and i
think we need to spend some time apart
not not to break up no i just i just
just some time
time apart to
figure ourselves out and and then and
then we come back together stronger
you know
this is
coming out of nowhere no it's not i've
i have i've tried to tell you like i'm
like a million different ways but you
don't listen see you that's the thing is
that you you never listen i don't need
this time apart for me i need this time
apart for us how long do you think it's
gonna take you to move okay this is
about the move you don't wanna help me
move wha what
i would i would love to help you move
that's what boyfriends do
claire i just think that it's a weird
coincidence that you need space right
when i'm about to move oh my god
oh my god
i am so sorry that i didn't plan my
emotional turmoil around your move
look at your face see and now you've
assumed the worst of me because you do
that and that's why we need to spend
time apart from each other that is not
fair
not
fair
babe all i'm asking for is 12 lousy
hours this saturday okay fine
okay fine
we'll move on sunday 48 hours i don't
know what i was thinking 12 hours
is nowhere near enough time to do what i
need to do
to make our relationship stronger see
you got me all
confused and you know what i love you
but i gotta get out of here i can't i
just can't i don't
i'm so confused right now i feel like i
can't think and the walls are closing in
on me and i just don't know what to do i
was my landlord
he says he doesn't want to lose me as a
tenant so he is not going to raise my
rent
now i don't have to leave my place
and i don't need time apart because
we're perfect together
will you marry me
you paint my apartment
yeah of course i'm painting your
apartment that's what boyfriends do what
when exactly do you think that's gonna
happen
what are we doing in this neighborhood
come on this place is in our price range
besides i mean people say the
neighborhood's turning around
it's jordan and kira we're here to view
the apartment at
three my bad
i had this homeless crackhead trying to
set up house in here yesterday almost
had to beat his ass man but y'all ain't
got nothing to worry about cause anybody
try to get up in here i will murder them
let me give y'all the tour all right so
we got these vintage windows they've
been here as long as the building been
here
hey
hey you look i see you out there you get
out that car and i will murder you
that's what i thought
the roll on luke
roll on
my nephew craig
you good kid
he's no crack though
you know that man
it's uh just in case
all right i filed a serial number off
there so if you got to shoot anybody
just make sure to wipe your fingerprints
off this month
oh come on y'all ain't gonna bite you
brand new covers
i put the contact paper in myself here
so y'all don't get no germs
ah ain't nothing
i thought craig was rolling back i ain't
getting shot by this twice damn while we
down here check this out
original hardwood floor from when the
building was built check out this green
brother
that is craftsmanship anyway come on
now this paint is all new
oh okay this this happened after i had
painted the funny story we got
crackheads in this neighborhood and one
of them living right next door here
right and one day he was smoking crack
just went looney tunes and mistook his
nine millimeter that's a pistol honey
for the remote control but don't worry
you ain't never gonna see him again
ain't nobody ever
gonna see him
again
plus i'm gonna put a fancy little hook
in there and turn it into a hat rack
now let's take a look at his bedroom
what up
i ain't found this place first found it
man i own this page can y'all give me a
second
gonna be first monster last month right
one month security deposit i'll get the
paperwork started
okay baby let's set this rock real quick
[Music]
it's your landlord
hey devon
hey how you doing brother
how you doing yeah just uh
stopping by
just wanted to
check up on everything you know
okay
you went here you little mother
nope
closet look good
door is strong so you all settling in
yeah
we've been living here a year and a half
so we have so uh how these cupboards uh
work it out for you
nobody in here
besides your stuff which looks good
thank you
completely unrelated
have y'all seen a 4 foot 11 dude with a
purple beard up in here no
no no no one's in here
probably because we locked the door
oh he got the body like a rat
he can just squeeze through the fence
yeah
so you think somebody's hiding in my
apartment no
i told you
it's just a social call
i mean why would gerald be in here
anyway gerald
there was a man with a purple beard
named gerald
in my apartment hell no why did you see
him about four foot nine got a purple
beard yeah hey baby
oh
hey baby girl
can you wait gerald
oh by the way have you seen a four foot
five purple beard baby
devon
what's going on
okay you know what i'm gonna level with
y'all
there was a four foot three with a
purple beard named gerald somewhere in
this building why does he keep getting
smaller every time you mention him
seriously cause i didn't want no alarm
y'all
he is disturbingly small really he's a
good guy
he's more rock though i mean he'll do
anything
to get money for crack
anything
okay
i mean
anything
i get it he
will
murder
you
well
we certainly hope you find him
oh i'm gonna find him
don't worry about that
cause i'm gonna look low
and then i'm gonna look
sound for the inconvenience y'all get my
hands on you you will be two foot three
[Music]